[Music]
what up guys goes on here back for
another attack on Titan review this time
we are looking at chapter 107 and I know
I say it like every time but this was an
insane chapter crazier than the last one
and we got a lot more information about
stuff that was hinted at back in the
beginning of the manga even I gotta say
it's almost torture reading these
monthly chapters because they end too
soon and I want to just keep reading and
find out wTF is going on but I guess we
got away I can't wait to hear what you
guys thought about this chapter let me
know in the comments and like always
I'll make an Instagram post and Twitter
post at anime uproar so you guys can let
me know your predictions for what will
happen in chapter 108 I'll read over
some correct predictions for this
chapter at the end of the video so stay
tuned for that if you're new to this
channel be sure to subscribe and hit
that notification well for more attack
on Titan videos especially with the
third season coming this month also if
you enjoyed these trap's reviews and
want to keep them coming Warhammer smash
that like button to let me know without
further ado let's jump right into this
informative chapter so we start with
runaway Aaron behind bars looking like a
boss by the way
hanji is asking him what he's doing
here's a weird moment kanji calls out
Aaron for telling himself to fight in
the mirror let me know what you think
about this scene hanji thinks he
wouldn't usually say that to himself nor
would she said as a herself so is Aaron
perhaps trying to convince someone else
are the memories of the Warhammer Titan
within him as well is he struggling to
contain all those memories including of
the attack founding and Warhammer Titan
in one body is he developing multiple
personalities that Griner did is he
trying to convince himself that what he
initially set out to do is still worth
it definitely let me know what you think
I found it interesting that hanji seemed
to make a big deal about it Aaron is
clearly not opening up and hanji is
having a lot of trouble figuring out how
to deal with them anyways hanji points
out that Aaron's new hair is a may
which is definitely true she also
romanís about how they used to talk
about titans for whole night and then I
believe Erin mentions that he was
certain that there was no need to
sacrifice Astoria which foreshadows what
we're gonna find out about his story of
this chapter some of you might have
heard but it's crazy then we jump into a
flashback from two years prior Jelena
comes and is met by the island dwellers
the port that they started when they
initially made contact is finished and
Jelena points out that a visitor is
coming from the only nation that will be
an ally to the free LD ins the visitor
is from the nation of his room which is
phonetically similar to a name for Japan
which translates to Land of the Rising
Sun the guest is the Ambassador Kiyomi
Asuma beetle which is a Japanese name so
clearly this country is the Japan of
this world
Asuma beetle is also a name associated
with a samurai and court official of
Japan's Nara period who died in the year
757 if you guys recall this is the same
woman who came to Willie Tyler's event
and covered up when judo spelled wine on
her while other ambassadors would have
probably exploded at odo for ruining
their outfit Jelena explains that she
has unprecedented high ties with foreign
countries so she's going to be very
important ally for the LD ins Mikasa
looks shocked when she sees another
Asian then Jelena asks me cosa doesn't
she look like your mother and points out
that they are from the same bloodline
she owe me makes me cuss a symbol of
three swords making a triangle or an A
and asks if Mikasa has seen it because I
was even more shocked when she sees the
symbol she shows the mark under her
bandaged arm and reveals it to the shock
of the ambassador this time way back in
Chapter five Mikasa is a flashback where
she remembers after her mother gave her
that brand how it hurt her mom told her
that she would have to pass it down that
day Mika says mom and dad were killed by
criminals now after 102 chapters we
finally figure out what this passing
reference is about I have legit wondered
about this for so long that I had a mini
freakout when we finally discovered it
and I had to even put around the
thumbnail as you guys probably saw
anyways Kiyomi reveals that more than
100 years ago the he's little who were
dressed in what appears to be all
Japanese outfits in the flashbacks we're
allies of the LDN Empire the ancestors
of the azuma beetle clan which is Mekas
us and her mom's clan was the son of the
Shogun in his room and he built a
friendly and intimate relationship with
the fritzsche royal family so they were
allowed to stay on Paradise Island
but when King fritz moved to the island
that his little people came to be seen
as traitors
perhaps because their memories could not
be erased and as a result they were
deemed threat some members of the clan
nonetheless stayed and now 100 years
later Kiyomi says that she's met one who
shares the same blood referring to
Mikasa and in a crazy revelation claims
that Mikasa is her nation's hope the
fruit of our lost citizens
apparently Mikasa is the survivor of the
top bloodline in the world
so Mika says not only part ackerman an
elite clan that was infused with special
powers using titan science to become
insanely powerful warriors but she is
also part of this top bloodline she
really does have an exceptionally
interesting identity then hanji points
out that they don't even know the world
very well
and pixie points out that they are
nothing but powerless babies in the
world beyond the ocean which is also a
good point again emphasizing their lack
of technological advancements and
complete dependence on aaron then we
jump to a story and she's excited that
Mika says like them referring to the
huge little people and believes that
this might ease the burden that they
were all born with including her heir
and weakest and the others Erin smiles
also seeming hopeful this happy Astoria
will stand in stark contrast to the one
we'll see a couple years later at the
end of the chapter but more on that
later
Yomi says to Mikasa that the people of
his rule are waiting for her she
explains that this was a historic day
because they could meet for the first
time paradise was being treated like its
own nation by another nation of the
world cleome says that this historic
event could only take place thanks
Zeke and then we get another piece of
information that I speculate about but
wasn't sure about until now another huge
revelation in the flashback Zeke reveals
that he never told Marley he had royal
blood because he was a member of the LD
and restorationist saying it had been
his father's duty ever since Zeke was
born so Zeke is carrying on his father's
Duty again this seems to confirm wise
eeeek says in chapter 83 Aaron that they
were both victims of their father
because even though they were so young
Grishka Yeager placed a ridiculously
heavy burden on them both then
Zeke reveals something that I had
guessed that as a seven year old he
realized that the male Titan biology
Research Society was extremely close to
finding the restorationist
that his father was leading which would
have meant Titan held on parody's for
his parents the restorationist his
grandparents and him so since his
parents would have been found out soon
Zeke sold out his parents so that he
could help advance the LDN cause it
might seem weird for seven-year-olds
figured all this out but keep in mind
Zeke is no ordinary person he is
probably the most intelligent person an
attack on titan so since he's a genius
this was not out of the realm of
possibility Zeke also agreed with his
parents that the restoration of the
great Aldean Empire was not something
that could be achieved by this laughable
group of idiots referring I believe to
the island dwellers on parodies so he
killed LD ends on Paradise Island to
keep his cover as long as he needed to
so that he could eventually save the LD
ends in general let me know if you guys
believe that Zeke is telling the truth
about this I know some of you still
doubt him and I get that too since he
did kill all those island dwellers after
all including Aaron was that really
necessary for his plan let me know what
you think
Zeke then explains that to move the
mechanism in three dimensional
maneuvering gear a special mineral
called ice burst stone is required which
is an underground resource exclusive to
parodies this by the way totally reminds
me of Sakura died from Code Geass a rare
mineral that was almost exclusive to
Japan and was necessary for making
advanced technology
operate most notably hose uses the power
source for nightmare frames there
definitely seems to be a clear parallel
here and I gotta say I definitely didn't
see this coming I don't even remember
anything like it being hinted at except
we did learn about the weird crystal
cave when the gang was fighting Kenny
and rod Reece but anyways the resource
serves Zeke well as a bargaining chip
Zeke tells Kiyomi that her nation can
become a great country with prospering
industry and she begins to salivate now
this scene really threw me off guard
since this woman seems so nice unlike so
many other outsiders but this scene
seems to suggest that all her actions
could be a result of her greed for
paradises resources even Mikasa begins
thinking that this lady is only using
her so really it seems like an attack on
Titan no one can really be trusted then
she goes on to mention Zeke's plans the
best plan is probably combining all
three together but they break them down
into three different possibilities so
possibility one experiment with the
earth and rumbling ability to show the
world their power I really want to see
this ability by the way to see if it
will actually work finally possibility
to involve his Lulu and empower
paradises military catching it up to the
rest of the world flattening of the
earth would not be necessary but it kind
of would be because modernization would
take 50 years so the option of
flattening the earth will still be
necessary for the protection of the
island until then and possibility 3 the
continued possession of the founding
titan and a titan of royal blood she
drops the bombshell that Zeke needs a
successor of the beasts tightened up
possesses royal blood so they can work
together with Aaron and his successors
to be able to activate earth and
rumbling before the 13 years are up for
the one with royal blood aka historia
she will need to raise more to take her
place so my understanding is that
historian will have to become the next
beast Titan and that she will have to
have children with someone and raised
them in order to eventually eat her and
repeat the process a hell of a process
to be sure
so that historian from a few years ago
who was so happy that their birds might
finally be lifted seems to be only
getting more burdens to carry and even
more tragic ones nevertheless his storia
steps up to the plate and accepts the
inheritance of the beast titan for the
sake of parodies let's give props how
much his story has grown she's come from
that innocent kind of shy and clumsy
girl in the beginning and grown into a
truly great queen who is even willing to
sacrifice her life and that of her
children for her nation let me know if
you think she's making the right move or
not in the comments all I know for sure
is that she's definitely matured a lot
and almost all the characters have been
forced to do the same because of their
circumstances man you say I'm a better
give us some ray of hope in the ending
of attack on Titan because at this point
things just keep getting bleaker and
bleaker Eren protests to Zeke's plan and
says that they should look for other
options then we jump to the present and
hanji says they still haven't found
another option hanji wonders why Eren
acted alone
and endangered parodies wondering if he
even cares about his story anymore since
his actions may have guaranteed an
attack from other nations and to ensure
safety they'll need to have access from
earth and rumbling which means historian
needs to inherit the beast Titan and
produce more royally blooded successors
then we seem to get a confirmation that
Aaron got the Warhammer Titan some of
you were thinking that Jos Titan got it
I was pretty sure that Aaron got it
although we still didn't see proof aaron
suggests that he does in fact have it
and that he can use his powers to get
out of the prison whenever he wants even
if it's on the ground
Aaron pretty much points out how him
being in a prison is a joke that they
can't kill him or Zeke they are really
powerless to do anything
then Aaron freaks out grabs hanji we see
in this scene how much Aaron has grown
physically and how much taller he is
than hanji now it's hard to believe he's
grown up so much he screamed sure is
there another way rather than committing
historian to that cruel fate kanji has
no answer she just calls Aaron a pervert
can someone explain to me why she does
that I gotta admit I'm not certain why
she does it all then we see that hanji
is struggling
thinking that erlan made a mistake
putting her in charge then we jumped
back to Sasha's grave where Nicolo is
attacked because he appears to be Mar
layin and Marlins caused these deaths
Niccolo came to pay his respects to
sasha we got some touching moments here
where Nicola once called to the island
Wohlers is so devastated over one of
them dying and even offers to cook for
her family and we get a funny moment
where the father asks if he'll cook for
free flooring that he'll charge them so
you can see some of Sasha's humor coming
in from him too
we also get a side line from Connie
saying that it feels like half of him
has disappeared after Sasha died which
is just sad
so asam is still pulling at our
heartstrings over Sasha's death which
makes sense because I'm glad they didn't
just skim over that it's getting the
treatment it should get next we have a
scene where parodies officials are given
stolen tightened serums from Jelena and
her people in a pretty unexpected turn
the government officials turn their
weapons on Jelena and the rest
vixie makes it clear that they are not
trying to kill yell and her people or
make them long-term enemies and wishes
that they can overlook their behavior
because there's no way they could not
keep Zeke a prisoner which makes sense
not only is he immensely valuable for
the well-being of the whole nation
he also freakin killed Erwin and so many
others so you can't really blame them
for not fully trusting him and his
people then we get Levi taking C to the
Titan forest with its trees that are
usually around 80 metres tall there's
also no rocks around so that Levi could
easily take down Z if he tried to escape
Zeke mentions how he'd like Gabi and
Falco to see this amazing scene of
nature then we jump to the imprisoned
kids Gabby
I'll say right off the bat is not
helping her cause at all so many people
hate her in the fan base and a lot of us
thought she would finally open her eyes
a bit when she came to parodies but nope
she fakes being sick a guard was worried
about her rushes in to help and she
brutally and I mean brutally murders him
by smashing his head with a brick
even Falkor marks
was brutal so security is definitely
lacking here but they probably didn't
think two kids can do anything big in
their defense but anyways yeah they get
away pretty pretty easily while they're
running away Falco tries to convince
Gabby that there's humanity and the
island dwellers and that these people
care for her but she can't believe what
doc was saying and still believes that
they are all Devils she clearly hasn't
learned anything I think she's even
surpassed Kidd Aaron and sheer blind
rage although she's going through a hard
time since she has no idea who she can
trust and her whole worldview is falling
apart she can't trust or anyone else she
says but still at this point it's almost
impossible to excuse her behavior in
actions and her complete refusal to even
hear Falco out let me know what you guys
are thinking about Gabby's actions and
what the two of them might do now that
they escape the prison but are still on
the island then we get a scene of the
Marlin
ldiots Reiner wakes up and is greeted by
peak and Porco and some alcohol
he immediately wonders where Gabby and
Falco are but before Porco and P can
answer him we jump to a pregnant
historia in front of a random house far
away from civilization although it might
not be random it might be where the
Reese family has been secluded for
generations a man comes out of the door
we don't see who it is but he appears to
have blond hair and tells her to come
back in and that she should be more
careful with her body Wow didn't I say
this chapter was crazy I still can't
believe we didn't make any progress with
Annie but so much information reveal and
so many things happen whose kid do you
think it may be and who do you think is
the man with historia
clearly his story did not escape any of
her burdens in fact more tragic ones
were placed upon her make sure to let me
know what you think will happen next on
the Instagram and Twitter post and now
let's turn to some Instagram and Twitter
predictions about this chapter Paulsen
Terry was right that we got to see
Reiner wake up but he assumed that Porco
would
held the warhammer tightened like many
others and this chapter suggests that
that's not the case although we haven't
seen the power actually being used yet
so it's possible however unlikely that
porco got the power of course Reiner is
worried about Gabby and Porco and
historia played a big role in this
chapter so nice call there I'm just
gonna call you just just was hoping for
a conversation between Aaron and Zeke
and I was too but I'm surprised we still
didn't get it we really need that
brotherly bonding time ASAP but they
were right about getting to see Reiner
peak and Porco recovering from the
battle as a number of you predicted
would happen like me do God was hoping
Annie would come out of the crystal but
we'll have to keep waiting for that but
he did guess that error might be
affected by the warhammer memories and
that definitely might be happening as I
mentioned earlier in the chapter
DJ underscore Vince six believed that
Zeke would get eaten by Aaron and Aaron
would inherit the royal blood and these
kinds of ideas have been circulating for
a while but I don't think that would
work it seems that there has to be a
living royal blooded Titan for Aaron's
founding powers to activate which is why
historia is having kids that can be
successors to the beasts Titan rather
than just offering herself to be eaten
by Aaron after she inherits the power
over on Twitter go stalker hope to see a
little more about Sasha and we got to
see her parents and her friends mourning
her one more time
he Cuddy was right that we got more
detail about Zeke's plan not to mention
his past which I'm psyched we finally
got lastly caster for life says that he
predicts the world explodes and the
manga ends in chapter 107 well that
didn't happen but maybe it happens in
chapter 108 well II am I mean you
clearly never know sorry if I didn't get
to read your comments this time but
thank you to everyone who commented on
posts let me know what you think will
happen in chapter 108 on Instagram or
Twitter and you maybe in the next video
let me know what you are most looking
forward to now I want to see Aaron use
the Warhammer Titan powers
I want to know who the father of
historias child is I want to see Annie
come out already and I want to see some
Titans I feel like it's been a minute
since we've seen some in action I also
want to know more about Nicholas clan
and what being from a top bloodline will
mean for her so that's it for today's
video thanks so much for watching till
the end I really hope you enjoyed this
chapter review and until next time see
ya space cowboys
[Music]
you